mais le retrait du projet de loi par
une partie du gouvernement n'arrête pas
mobilisation de cette force excédentaire pour
mettre du plaisir sans changement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
C'est incroyable qu'on soit dans cette crise
vivre cette violence qui traverse
pays et un gouvernement d'avoir un
La réforme fiscale est terminée
les jeunes apparaissant plus aux gens
nous sommes fatigués de quoi
l'occasion de l'heure d'élargir et
alors
l'éducation coûte très cher derrière
fait qu'ils veulent mettre des réformes qui vont
à faire
j'ai déjà sans égal
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Oh
[Applaudissements]
Yo
la réforme est une nécessité de la retirer ou
n'a pas demandé au congrès de
république le retrait du projet
déposée par le ministère des Finances et
traiter d'urgence une nouvelle
projet fruit d'un consensus et donc
éviter l'incertitude financière
Yo
[Musique]
Oh
et
[Musique]
Oh
Yo
[Musique]
pour
nous ne voulons plus de morts nous ne voulons pas
saigner à mort et rejeter ces actes de
violence que l'État colombien vient
prendre contre nous
[Musique]
sont ces vandales qui se fondent et ont
développé des actes prémédités
organisée et financée par des groupes de
dissidents de la faria lln ceux qui
chercher à déstabiliser certaines régions
à des fins particulières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]